hey guys this is my first ever YouTube
livestream I really hope this works
I just did the twitch stream I think
people were able to watch and hear me
it's gonna be hard to kayak
and stream and talk at the same time but
I'll try my best
hello Liam Donnelly the first commenter
good to see you
I've been doing a lot of just content
sorry get out of breath kayaking is is
actually it takes a lot of like those of
you who might be new or haven't watched
my other content I'm in Benassi Spain
right now I'm in the midst of playing a
tournament just finished round six
yesterday round seven is today I'm
actually in another town now called a
restate Spain neighbouring minovsky it's
it's basically in the heart of the
Pyrenees surrounded by mountains people
can see all directions
there's just mountains in the middle of
a lake right now I just went it's like a
45 minute walk from the hotel paid $15
for 15 euros for an hour of kayaking
this was basically my my preparation for
round seven playing decently rated
master from from Spain today
haven't really done much chest
preparation but sometimes in these long
and grueling events you just have to you
have to relax do some non chef stuff to
to find the balance
so yeah the tournament has been going
going okay I've played a couple of
grandmasters unfortunately routed to
against the GM's I got sort of outplayed
yesterday by a grandmaster from Israel
by the name of Dan Zoeller about 2500
feet eh but it was an instructive game
and I'll be going over all of my games
daily on coach Djokovic skis YouTube
channel I'm sure people can search that
or find it in some other video
descriptions someone was asking what
opening I'm playing today I don't really
know I'm playing someone who just plays
a lot of random things I looked him up
in the database and he's playing like
against e4 e5 he's playing King's gambit
he's playing Vienna
he's playing Evans gambit against
Sicilian his most recent game was in the
wing gambit but before I moved to so
it's one of those players I don't really
want to prepare for it because you can
play anything so I feel like the best
preparation is just trying to enjoy life
and going into the game which i think is
really important for especially in these
long chess tournaments that you don't
overload on chess between rounds I don't
know a lot of players like in downtime
all they do is look at chess they spend
hours of preparation that's essentially
what I did last year just by preparing
hours and hours before every game I
realized that most of my games I'll be
out of preparation relatively early so
my goal for this tournament is exactly
what Mateo gari Leo is saying just
playing and enjoying and hopefully that
that serves well in terms of
of just having a good performance and
enjoying the overall experience
so anyway I'm probably gonna keep this
brief because this is I'm assuming this
is gonna eat up a lot of data I just
bought the sim card yesterday Oh Matt
Matt Matteo bought my DVD or wait no
your DVD on the London looks very cool
yeah that was another thing I released
of course it's not necessarily a DVD I
guess you could buy like the physical
DVD I know if anyone uses those anymore
hello - Tim Tim three LPS but I do have
a course out it was released like three
days ago on the London System eight
hours of recording I'm sure people could
find it if you check my Twitter or my
other YouTube stuff uh where am I
I should have put this in the title I'm
in Spain I'm just in the middle of a
lake but but I just wanted to say thank
you to everyone who's been following my
content the channel has really grown
with him last month I think now close to
4,000 subscribers and I think I've had
about 3,000 subscribers in the last
month so I do appreciate the love if
anyone has any feedback if you want to
see specific chest contents or if you
want to see you like more lifestyle
stuff for Q&A or or more live streams
this is my first time at least live
streaming on YouTube I'm a bit more
active on Twitch but it feels like the
YouTube audience has been is growing
more rapidly so anyway Ignacio Roberto
from South America French please says
Matteo French as in like the language
French or the opening French because I
guess I could do either actually I
played east 6 against d4
the other day and one of my games never
played e6 against e4
but then it transposed to a London
system so it wasn't really a French Kjar
D was watching beating London and
classical games good timing
yeah this is uh this is hopefully the
first of many live streams and now bugs
are attacking me I put bug spray on like
an hour ago maybe it wore off anyway I'm
gonna end it here because I have a
limited amount of data but thanks guys
for watching and hopefully I'll I'll do
more of these in the future
see you guys